diot mort est là quand tu es journaliste
spécialiste de l'afrique bonsoir ça du
marais le planter merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france alors avant de
signer un accord formel en le maréchalat
star aurait besoin de deux jours
supplémentaires pour l'étudier est-ce
qu'on peut il croire encore à cet accord
alors patrice desbiens de c'est
tellement embourbé et les différentes
protagonistes qui rentre en lice
actuellement ne sont pas faits pour
alléger l'ambiance quand avatar avait
pour allier les russes aujourd'hui sa
rage à pour rallier la turquie sur un
contrat sur un quartier de mer qui a
priori semble illégal et donc pris un
autre débat dans le débat déjà très
brouillé du conflit libyen mais alors
c'est haftar demande quelques jours de
réflexion
j'espère que ça pourra lui permettre
d'intégrer les toubous dont on ne parle
pas dans ce conflit
j'espère aussi qu'ils vont intégrer
l'union africaine qui a pourtant une
commission qui devrait avoir son mot et
on voit que c'est plutôt un débat entre
occidentaux méditerranée et s'il ya des
africains c'est sur la bande aux
méditerranéennes aussi jusqu'en égypte
ça s'arrête là justement vous nous dit
on n'en parle pas pourquoi est ce si
important d'intégrer ces partis il a
expliqué nous mais c'est sur le
continent africain
et vous voyez bien que depuis la
déflagration l'agression de la
déliquescence de la libye comment le mal
et on souffre pas que tous ces pays au
sud du sahara sont tributaires des
dégâts collatéraux de la déliquescence
de la libye le terrorisme qui sont
nourris et on nous a mis en même temps
comme commission de l'ue de
du haut niveau pour la gestion de la
crise en libye comme africains denis
sassou nguesso qui lui-même du congo
brazzaville qui est lui-même un qui lui
m'interresse son peuple donc pourquoi il
n'apparaît pas dans ce dossier pourquoi
l'afrique me ne paraît pas dans la
gestion de cette crise dont on aimerait
bien avoir de plus amples explications
est-ce que c'est dû à l'attitude pas
qu'on qualifie de non-démocratique de
sassou qui emprisonne et là à noël vient
de faire quatre prisonniers
supplémentaires
est ce qu'on ne veut pas en rajouter a
déjà ce qui est trés brouillées dans
cette gestion il ya autant de questions
que nous nous posons et nous aimerions
savoir pourquoi l'afrique nepad n'est
pas présente en tout cas sa rage a
accepté de signer effectivement l'a dit
mme shalev tard hésite ajoute il selon
vous comment vous vous l'expliquer mais
c'est je pense que le nouvel à la
turquie caisseux nouvelle année lamb est
un peu parce que vous fragilisez cesser
sa marge de manoeuvre par rapport à la
turquie qui lui offre à pas pardon à la
russie qui même si c'est pas de façon
officielle il bénéficie quand même des
armements russes via les mercenaires
donc voir que la rivalité
s'internationalise que des enjeux des
personnalités nouvelles nous ajoute à ça
va le braquet et lui il va demander bien
sûr un temps de réflexion pour pouvoir
aussi peut-être avoir d'autres alliés et
pouvoir avoir une plus large marge de
manoeuvre afin de pouvoir partir en
position de force dans les négociations
elles vous parliez de la turquie
effectivement récepteur d'organes le
président turc s'est fait plus menaçant
prévenant qu'il n'hésiterait pas je cite
a infligé une leçon à l'homme fort de
l'est libyen s'est pas vraiment
une ambiance très diplomatique tout ça
il faut dire que dwan à 35 milliards sur
ce pays là et qu'il a investi des
milliers de milliards de milliards de
milliards dans ce domaine là avant que
la libye ne sont à ce point là donc il y
à une manne économique a récupéré des
entreprises turques eux qui étaient là à
récupérer et non seulement en plus une
union il veut compter il va avoir sa
part dans ce quartier de la méditerranée
qui produit du gaz et donc est très
gourmand de la turquie donc grands
enjeux économiques
angers évidemment je sors la ramener je
sais pas s'il existe de conflits de
gains engrangés économique
c'est comme on dit chez nous quand les
éléphants se battent c'est l'art qui
souffrent dans le coeur au détriment des
populations les enjeux économiques sont
là et qui cause des effets ressentis
équipe est prise et font des déplacés
internes
il y en a tellement aujourd'hui depuis
la chute de la libye dans chaque pays du
sahel il ya des déplacés internes qui
risque de s'accentuer si la question
libyenne n'est pas réglée et comment le
régler
j'aimerais aussi qu'on en parle alors
oui justement comment le régler il ya
une solution en tout cas c'est ce qu'ils
espèrent cette conférence internationale
sur la libye qui aura lieu à berlin le
19 janvier vous êtes optimiste vous y
croyez à ce règlement via cette
conférence vous sous l'égide de l'onu on
le rappelle un sous l'égide de générer
que
ce qui serait bien ce qui sera important
c'est de fédéraliser déjà ce pays parce
que d'un côté quelqu'un qui est
militairement fort et d'autre part sa
rage qui a tout le soutien international
avec les nations unies et qui a un
gouvernement d'union nationale
ça fait un déséquilibre qui
déséquilibrent aussi d'autres tribus lui
comme les toubous qui sont bien de là
bas et qui ne sont pas tenus en compte
est ce que si finalement on arrivait à
une fédéralisation et un gouvernement de
2,2 un gouvernement qui va chapeauter
tout ça ça nous éviterait pas un vivier
souveraine
c'est ça une lubie laisser ce soit a
priori l'onu et c'est ce à quoi devrait
servir cette conférence voilà donc on
arriver à ça serait vraiment l'idéal il
faudrait donc que les uns et les autres
acceptent de se départir de partie de
leur souveraineté temps pour sa rage que
pour certains dont on y arrive et les
pays peut-être tourné le dos alors
justement leurs intérêts économiques
vous croyez que c'est possible ça que le
pays tourne à huy que la turquie oui
voilà que les pays effectivement qui
sont très impliqués dans ce conflit
tourne le dos à leurs propres intérêts
peut-être aidé c'est lily ce sont réels
je pense que l'om va faire beaucoup de
chantage par rapport à la présence
militaire qui va mettre en
la disposition de de sarnez qui sera qui
pourra équilibrer ses relations avec le
maréchal donc y va compter il pèsera et
peut-être qu'il arrivera à redessiner la
carte la carte maritime dans cette
partie de la méditerranée là et ce sont
nos objectifs je crois qu israël
laissera pas faire où on lui cédera des
parties dans ce qui ne lui revient pas
de droit où il mettrait du feu à la
poudre on verra ça merci des besoins de
l'huile sur le feu merci sadio
morel tentait d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france marie adam